betreten parteivorsitzenden der fdp
johannes vogel sie sind teil des
sondierungsteams dass sich morgen mit
den grünen trifft herr vogel und wir
haben alle zur kenntnis genommen dass
sich wolfgang kubicki schon mal seine
gedanken gemacht hat zu armin laschet
ich vermute mal dass
das armin laschet diese woche nicht
überstehen wird seine autorität wird
öffentlich infrage gestellt ich kann mir
schwer vorstellen wie er mit einer union
die nicht komplett zu 100 prozent hinter
ihm stehe die herausforderung genießen
dagegen stehen will so ist es ein
klassischer kubicki also wenn armin
laschet die woche nicht übersteht dann
könnten sie auch die cdu nicht mehr zur
verfügung haben für verhandlungen und
müssten mit wem reden also die reden ja
mit parteien nicht mit einzelpersonen
und aber wolfgang ist ja immer für eine
forsche formulierung gut mein eindruck
ist dass armin laschet sonntag mit uns
zusammen sitzen wird mit anderen denn
das gespräch ist ja vereinbart worden
und das ist dann ende der woche also
offensichtlich ist politik dynamischen
nicht alles tritt so einen wie jede oder
jeder kollege oder ihre kolleginnen
erwartet und dann müssen sie zuerst mal
mit dem wolfgang reden optimiert dass
das war ja es war eine erwartung kein
wunsch nein ich glaube es geht darum was
irgend was ganz anderes wir sind doch
das muss man doch mal festhalten werden
doch offensichtlich die situation dass
die ära merkel ende mit einem ganz neuen
parteien system nämlich mit dem
parteiensystem ich rede jetzt nur was
demokratische spektrum von vier mehr
oder weniger mittel großen parteien zwei
ein bisschen größeren aber mittelgroßen
die über 75 prozent oder rund 75 prozent
jeweils nicht gewählt haben zwei etwas
kleineren aber mittelgroßen in
sichtweite die jeweils zweistellige
wahlergebnisse haben wir gerade sehr
stark von denen jung und erstwählern
gewählt was mich sehr gefreut hat und
das ist ganz neu und jetzt haben wir die
herausforderung dar auch was gutes neues
zu machen denn jamaika wenn man eben
über jamaika 2017 gehört dass es doch
vor allem auch am mangel an großen
denken gescheitert jetzt sind die
aufgaben nicht kleiner geworden und die
auf frage ist jetzt welche konstellation
kann sich auf einen großen wurf für eine
erneuerungs koalition oder
modernisierungs koalition verständigen
mal darum geht's fürs land super gut
zusammengefasst wenn man sich dieses
elfi nochmal anschaut von grünen und
gelb das sogenannte citrus elfi da ist
irgendwie eigentlich für einen
zusätzlichen menschen nicht platzt aber
es müsste ja ein kanzler noch mit drauf
welcher wäre denn ihr lieblings kanzler
ja dass ich habe ja gerade erklärt dass
mir darum geht nicht was er machen wir
den nächsten vier wochen für eine
inszenierung sondern das machen wir die
nächsten vier jahre führen programm und
ich finde es sehr gut dass gerade grüne
und fdp sich jetzt als erstes mal
zusammensetzen denn wir etwas neu ist
dann muss man vielleicht auch mit einem
neuen zugang angehen und dass wir als
diejenigen die glaube ich jeweils für
erneuerung stehen die in den letzten
jahren in der opposition waren die cdu
hat 16 jahre unter angela merkel regiert
die spd hat aber auch 19 der letzten 23
jahre regiert und olaf scholz ist
vizekanzler dieser groko und das da
erstmal die kräfte die für erneuerung
stehen aus ganz unterschiedlichen
richtungen kommt versuchen gucken zu
gucken gibt es vielleicht einen
kaminbrand bei uns gibt es vielleicht
ein kern einer eines programms worauf
wir uns verständigen können und dann zu
gucken mit wer kommt dazu dass doch mal
ein anderes heran wir sind es ja wohl
nicht anderes herangehen das ist richtig
aber es war eine antwort auf eine nicht
gestellte frage ich wollte von ihnen
gerne wissen ob sie einen lieblings
kanzler haben sowie ihr
parteivorsitzender wie christian lindner
der sagt er würde eigentlich am liebsten
von armin laschet reden also ich habe in
diesem wahlkampf und wir als freie
demokraten wir haben ja nicht für eine
koalition geworben sondern für unsere
konzepte und es ist ja offenkundig die
grünen haben das vor der wahl gesagt
wenn ich wahlprogrammen nebeneinander
legen dann gibt es bei denen mehr
gemeinsamkeiten zwischen den
wahlprogrammen von spd und grünen wenn
ich war programme nebeneinander legen
gibt es mehr gemeinsamkeiten zwischen
den wahlprogrammen von fdp und cdu und
csu also union aber jetzt ist ja nicht
die spannende frage was passt
mathematisch bei wahlprogramm sondern
wie kommt man gemeinsam auf ein konzept
der bewegt sich wie findet man einen
gemeinsamen grund eine gemeinsame
richtung das ist das was für die
nächsten tage klären und ganz viel ist
nicht neu ist katrin göring-eckardt
sitzen immer noch fraktionsvorsitzende
von bündnis 90/die grünen ist von
behring eckert wenn
sie sagen sie sind nun auch bei diesen
sondierungen mit dabei ab morgen wenn
sie sagen dass die union in ihren augen
nicht mal mehr regierungsfähig ist aber
eben auch nicht mal sondierungs fähig
ist warum machen sie das also wenn
andere die union schon abschreiben aber
warum es ist klug wenn man sagt cdu csu
sollen eigentlich dagegen nicht mal mehr
ein angebot machen nein das habe ich
nicht gesagt ich hab gesagt im moment
und das habe ich auch so gemeint das war
der tag an dem sich alles zerlegt hat
als die
fraktionsvorsitzenden wahl in der unions
fraktion eigentlich quasi erst mal gar
nicht stattfinden konnte und wenn man
alles darüber gelesen hat oder gehört
hat dann weiß man das ist keine
kraftausdrücke benutzer und aber sie
fand am ende statt genau und jetzt habe
ich ja gelernt es gibt am sonntag erste
gespräche mit der fdp und vorher muss
aber die union untereinander vor
sondieren mir gab dass so ein kleines
déjà vu wenn csu und cdu erst mal
miteinander sprechen müssen was sie dann
da wollen also insofern ist sagt
trotzdem unter demokratinnen und
demokraten ist sehr gut wenn man am ende
sprechen kann wenn man auch weiß wer
spricht und ob man eine gemeinsame idee
davon hat und dafür stehe ich glaube
allerdings auch man braucht ja in der
schwierigen zeit in der wir sind die
leute kommen aus der korona pandemie und
sind zurecht und verständlicherweise
gestresst wie wir glaube ich alle auch
die veränderungen die vor uns sind die
transformation die wir brauchen aufgrund
der klimakrise werden große
herausforderungen seien da braucht man
eine regierung die stabil ist da braucht
man eine regierung die das angehen will
da braucht man eine regierung die will
dass alle mitkommen können stadland als
jungen dass das wird die aufgabe sein
und dieses wir sind vor eine aufgabe die
sehr sehr viel größer ist der kleinste
gemeinden regelrecht besprechen und
werden uns auch fragen ob es vielleicht
für die zitrus koalition ganz gut sein
kann einen nicht zu starken kanzler zu
haben und vor sich zu wählen aber erst
mal sei der wahlgewinner begrüßt er
heilt das ist eine schöne um nicht zu
sagen eine wirklich auch neue situation
für die spd dann mal im bund eine weil
sieg einzufahren das hat er die partei
lange nicht
regieren oder regenerieren ist jetzt
natürlich die frage der union und wenn
sie so freundlich sind schauen wir
erstmal auf die die spd hat das auch
schon mal erfolgreich gemacht sich zu
regenerieren in einer großen koalition
warum sollte das der union nicht
gelingen denken sie ich glaube wir
müssen das mal zur kenntnis nehmen dass
die bürgerinnen bürger gesprochen haben
am letzten sonntag und da haben sowohl
personen als auch programme eine rolle
gespielt die fdp hatte angebote die
grünen hatte welche cdu wir auch und es
gab ja auch kanzlerkandidaten und ich
glaube ein signal ist dass die
bürgerinnen und bürger jedenfalls
ausweislich der umfragen mehrheitlich
olaf scholz zutrauen das amt des
kanzlers zu können aber richtig ist auch
dass wir koalitionen bilden müssen da
geht es um inhalte und die frage die
kann ich an alle drei anknüpfen ist was
ist gut für einen aufbruch in
deutschland und katrin göring-eckardt
hat gesagt dafür braucht man erstmal
eine stabile regierung parteien die mit
sich selbst im reinen sind mein eindruck
ist die fdp ist ganz bei sich bündnis 90
die grünen sind das und die
sozialdemokratie nach einer ganz langen
strecke auch von klärungsprozessen auch
das zweite ist was ist inhaltlich
notwendig für unser land und wie kriegt
man eine vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit
in ich glaube schon wir haben
unterschiedliche größen aber dass es um
eine partnerschaft auf augenhöhe geht
und wir können auch einen neuen stil in
dieser regierung bilden bitten davon bin
ich überzeugt nicht der stil des
gegenseitigen belauern olaf scholz hat
das gesagt eine regierung die unser land
erneuert weil da drei parteien jetzt
miteinander inhaltlich fragen klären
müssen aber vor allen dingen in sich
auch fortschritts parteien sind mit
unterschiedlichen nuancen mein lieblings
aufbruch und fortschritt glaube ich
merken wir uns wie häufig das feld ganz
kurz ein gedanke noch hinzu heute
tatsächlich erstmal über die union reden
ja und ich verstehe dass sie das nicht
möchten aber es ist tatsächlich ganz
spannend zu verstehen welche schlüsse
sie aus dem schicksal der union wenn ich
noch mal ganz kurz danach frage warum
glauben sie ist es jetzt nicht genauso
möglich dass die union sich auch in
einer potenziellen regierung
regenerieren kann und warum denken sie
ist sie nicht wahlsieger geworden ich
habe den eindruck aber das muss peter
altmaier besser beurteilen aber das ist
ja auch thema in der union dass die
union für sich fragen zu klären hat auch
die frage was inhaltlich ihr anspruch
ist man kann übrigens auch in der
opposition verantwortung für das land
übernehmen das haben bündnis 90 die
grünen auch die fdp durchaus getan ich
glaub was für deutschland wichtig ist
dass man etwas vorhat dass wir den staat
modernisieren dass wir den staat
digitalisieren dass wir den sozialstaat
auch entbürokratisieren dass wir zum
beispiel auch eine moderne
einwanderungspolitik machen ich wusste
ja mit der union an fachkräfte anderes
gesetz verhandeln ich glaube dass wir in
der konstellation eine klügere
qualifizierte zuwanderungspolitik
hinbekommen können ich habe den eindruck
mit verlaub das nach 16 jahren angela
merkel den cdu auch zeit braucht um sich
als volkspartei zu erneuern und die zeit
sollte man sich dann auch neben die
bielerinnen und weder die wirren bürger
haben gesprochen fragen wie die leichen
natürlich peter altmaier aber erstmal
sehen tatsächlich robin alexander den
stellvertretenden chefredakteur der welt
robin alexander jamaika jamaika war ein
großer plan und ein plan der tatsächlich
auch in 217 erwähnten bündnis schon
einmal angedacht und an verhandelt war
und dann am ende an der fdp scheiterte
würden sie sagen dass man jamaika heute
ohne armin laschet denken kann würden
sie sagen dass die die da noch fantasien
haben diesen platz mit markus söder
besetzen wenn man denn von jamaika noch
träumt ja auf jeden fall das ist muss
gar nicht unbedingt markus söder sein es
war ja um ein haar das armin laschet
schon am dienstag gestürzt wurde diese
neue aufstellung der fraktionsspitze
gelangte er seine vielen stunde vor der
sitzung und wer immer ihn beerbt hätte
ob das
einsparen gewesen wäre oder ein norbert
röttgen die wären alle anschlussfähig
für jamaika vielleicht mit der einen
ausnahme friedrich merz das würde
wahrscheinlich nicht gehen aber die
union könnte aber bei einer
neuaufstellung vielleicht sogar noch
glaubwürdiger diese
diese konstellation werden das erinnert
noch einmal an ihr jüngstes buch sie
haben über angela merkel ein buch
geschrieben mit dem titel machtverfall
wird ihr nachfolger wird ihr nachfolger
im amt schon ohnmächtig staaten denken
sie
das kommt darauf an wer es wird also
olaf scholz wird bestimmt nicht
ohnmächtig starten und wenn sie auf das
amt des cdu parteivorsitz sind armin
laschet ist nicht ohnmächtig armin
laschet ist eine ganz seltsame situation
er kann immer noch kanzler werden
theoretisch dazu müsste allerdings die
ampelkoalition sich verheddern oder wenn
er das nicht schafft dann ist er
politisch eigentlich tot also es ist
eine ganz seltsame konstellation alles
oder nichts die aber natürlich ihn
erpressbar macht und wenn es dazu käme
dass jamaika tatsächlich verhandelt
könnten sowohl die grünen als auch die
fdp dann eine menge rausholen das heißt
wir wissen nicht ob armin laschet er auf
dem jamaika kanzler stuhl sessel sondern
vielleicht ein anderer politiker und sie
würden was sagen robin alexander hat mit
der situation der union eigentlich
angela merkel noch zu tun nein sie hat
sich ja auch immer erkennbarer
inhaltlich davon abgewendet also sie hat
ja in letzter zeit termine gemacht bei
greenpeace und auf frauen filmpremieren
also erkennbar geht sie auf abstand zu
ihrer alten parteien familie die hat ja
auch erst ganz spät in den wahlkampf
eingegriffen als es eigentlich fast so
aus als gehe die union komplett unter
also sie möchte nicht die totengräber in
der union sein dass wir sie nicht auf
ihrem in dem geschichtsbuch stehen habe
aber dass sie jetzt wahnsinnig anteil
noch am geschehen das glaube ich nicht
ich glaube sie hat den kanzlerschaft gut
zu ende gebracht sich ist selbstbestimmt
gegangen und immerhin auch wenn olaf
scholz gewählt wird er ist ja gewählt
worden mit der aussage ich mache euch
die merkel ich mache kontinuität das gab
es ja auch noch nie das sozusagen die
parteien farbe wechselt aber der
kontinuität anspruch bleibt also alles
was scholz tut stellt er ja in das erbe
merkels und das ist doch scheiden die
kanzlerin schöne sache und damit sind
wir noch mal bei johannes vogel die fdp
hat einen kanzler mit 25 prozent als
ohnehin schwach bezeichnet und das ist
auch korrekt das so zu tun
man ist kein starker kanzler mit 25
prozent würden sie sagen dass es sogar
von vorteil sein könnte für gelb grün
wenn man sich von den beiden schwächeren
dann für den noch schwächeren
entschieden also für armin laschet also
ich habe niemanden als schwach
bezeichnet ich wünsche mir eine starke
regierung die frage ist ja wie wir die
bekommen und mit der frage müssen wir
uns noch beschäftigen und es ist richtig
und das ist einfach das neue was ich
eben beschrieben habe am neuen parteien
system das zum beispiel grüne und fdp
zusammen mehr unterstützung haben mehr
stimmen im bundestag als sowohl spd als
auch cdu das ist wirklich neu und dann
muss man auch eine neue art von
koalitionsbildung in bildung schaffen
und ich finde ganz spannend was robin
alexander gerade gesagt hat mir ist das
auch aufgefallen die cdu hat 16 jahre
die kanzlerin gestellt olaf scholz hat
sich für die spd habitat als merkel
nachfolger inszeniert ja bis hin zur
raute auf dem titelbild des sz-magazins
mein gefühl ist dass vielleicht gerade
dieser politik modus auch etwas ist was
wir hinter uns lassen müssen denn mein
eindruck ist dass wir in vielen stellen
nicht gut dastehen als land weil der
digitalisierung hinten dran sind bei der
rente kein konzept haben stand heute im
gesetzblatt wie das dauerhaft
funktionieren soll klimaschutzpolitik
besser werden muss also bei der
dekarbonisierung nicht vorankommt
vielleicht liegt das auch daran dass wir
in den letzten jahren uns zu sehr an und
politik modus gewöhnt haben der immer
nur auf sicht fährt er immer nur bis
ende der legislaturperiode denkt die
geistlichen jahrzehnten denken müssen
wieder in größeren wurf wagen und das
ist nämlich eine der prüf fragen wie ich
einer neuen konstellation stelle
inhaltlich und das ist die entscheidende
frage für die nächsten tage mal nach
jamaika ist nehmen sie nicht kommen und
dann kommen wir zu einer neuen regierung
die auch eine ampel natürlich beinhalten
könnte
mit robert habeck und mit winfried
kretschmann gibt es große fans von
jamaika die haben eigentlich immer ein
schwarz grünes bündnis und ein schwarz
gelb grünes bündnis
besser betrachtet oder befürwortet mehr
befürwortet als die ampel
würden sie sagen dass es vielleicht
wirklich sogar ganz gut sein könnte wenn
es einen schwächeren kanzler gebe also
man sich für armin laschet oder nicht
armin laschet sondern jemandem anderen
aus der union entschieden
und gegen die ampel ich glaube so kann
man nicht politik machen in diesen
zeiten also dass das wird nicht
funktionieren dass man sagt wir suchen
uns jetzt mal den schwächeren dann
könnten wir vielleicht stärker aussehen
sondern es geht wirklich darum dass
partnerin partner zusammenarbeiten und
ich würde jetzt sagen klar wir werden
reden wir werden auch mit der union
reden und gucken mal mit wem wir dann
reden und wer da die macht hat ich finde
es auch folgerichtig ist alles andere
wäre auch ein verrat an der demokratie
aber wenn ich mir anschaue wo wir jetzt
stehen
dann macht es keinen sinn darüber
nachzugrübeln wie könnte man denn
eigentlich irgendwas zusammen basteln
was einen schwachen hat einen der ein
bisschen stärker ist das ist doch die
frage des neuen stils von regierungen
die hat ja viele aspekte also das eine
ist das klar ist man sollte nicht
nebeneinander regieren sondern
miteinander und am besten wirklich
gemeinsam so dass was größeres ganzes
entsteht das zweite ist wir sollten auch
nicht mehr so uns im keller einsperren
oder im tunnel sein und sagen wir
regieren hier mal so ein bisschen vor
uns hin bürgerinnen und bürger
einbeziehen ganz wichtiger punkt das
haben ja gemerkt in den letzten jahren
dass leute quasi verzweifelt sind wir
irgend jemand über sie bestimmt hat das
ist müssen andere regierungsstil werden
indem wir mit bürgerinnen und bürger
bürger räte wie auch immer sehr viel
mehr reden ein junger leute die auf der
straße sind also die fdp es von jungen
leuten gewählt und bündnis 90 die grünen
auch das ist ein wichtiges signal und
die frage wie wird es mit dem
klimaschutz machen diese berechtigen
genau die klimakrise bewältigen ist eine
gigantische aufgabe es ist wirklich eine
gigantische aufgabe auch weil wir so
spät dran sind und das wird nicht gehen
wenn man sie nicht alle haben hier ein
kleines karo macht in der politik das
heißt großes denken darauf kommt es an
und dann hoffen wir darauf dass das
funktioniert man wird ja auch übrigens
egal was passiert immer auch die andere
partei familie brauchen weil viele dinge
wenn wir im bundesrat entscheiden und
deswegen macht es auch gar keinen sinn
sich jetzt wahnsinnig zu zerstreiten
sondern auch da müssen diese großen
aufgaben mit angepackt zukunftsteam
zukunft viel mehr altmaier haben
vorgestellt bekommen von armin laschet
und ein klima team braucht man für ein
solches zukunftsprojekt dass die union
jetzt immer noch an notiert nicht
wirklich auch zukünftige köpfe die sind
bei den verhandlungen nicht zwingend
mitarbeiter ist zwar frau beyer und frau
bär noch mit dabei aber ansonsten
menschen die armin laschet unterstützt
haben ja das ist richtig aber es ist
auch so dass bei diesen sondierungen in
aller regel nicht die künftigen
regierungsmannschaft zusammen kommen
sondern diejenigen die legitimiert sind
weil sie parteivorsitzende
generalsekretäre fraktionsvorsitzende
sind das war bei allen sondierungen ich
habe schon einige erlebt den wirt
gemacht der fall ich glaube dass der
entscheidende punkt ist wir brauchen in
grundlegenden fragen einen
parteiübergreifenden konsens wir haben
die den ausstieg aus der kernenergie
erst dann geklärt gemeinsam als es von
allen mitgetragen wurde wir haben die
zustimmung zur bundeswehr zum westlichen
bündnis erst erreicht als die spd in
godesberg sich zur marktwirtschaft und
zu europa bekannt hat und deshalb glaube
ich egal wer am ende regiert und egal
wir haben in der opposition ist dass wir
diesen konsens stärken müssen im übrigen
es ist darauf hingewiesen worden
wir haben die parteien der mitte haben
diese wahl gewonnen nicht die extreme
wurden gestärkt nicht die afg auch nicht
die links beginnt darüber hand freuen
uns jetzt schon vier tage und wir
bleiben noch einmal bei der situation
der union
wird übermittelt und wir erinnern es so
dass sie im frühjahr sich immer für
markus söder ausgesprochen haben war
weil sie gesagt haben es ist wichtig was
die menschen an der basis denken wir
können hier nicht nur in den gremien
entscheiden noch mal hand aufs herz und
die frage denken sie dass heute immer
noch hatte die union den falschen
kandidaten oder macht sie sich jetzt
einfach indem man sagen haben jetzt
schon ein dass man es war doch damals so
dass wir alle im april in einem abstand
von vier monaten zur wahl uns die frage
stellen muss mit wem haben wir die
größten chancen wenn man 16 jahre
regiert hat übrigens 100 bin ich mit dem
kollegen vogel nicht einer meinung wir
brauchen uns für diese regierungszeit
nicht zu stemmen deutschland steht
stärker da als zuvor der wohlstand ist
wachsen und auch im klimaschutz haben
wir nicht so viel erreicht wie notwendig
aber immerhin wir sind vorangekommen so
und damals und
seiner damals habe ich das ist ja
öffentlich bekannt geworden nicht durch
mich aber weil aus dem
cdu-bundesvorstand
einige die information bereitwillig
gestreut haben ich habe damals
argumente auch vorgetragen für markus
söder ist einer der anerkanntesten
politiker in deutschland
er hatte respekt weit über die grenzen
von bayern hinaus und das war für mich
ein wichtiger gesicht ich habe
allerdings anderen danach auch armin
laschet selber ja den bundestags
wahlkampf unterstützt denn wenn
demokratische entscheidung getroffen
sind dann durch die sie auch in der
basis argumentiert sie haben ja gesagt
unsere basis also stichwort herr
kretschmer der immer noch tief entsetzt
ist und sich fragt ob in vier jahren von
der union noch was übrig ist sie haben
damit argumentiert dass die menschen
draußen nicht verstehen wie gremien in
der union entschieden haben das müssten
sie noch heute denken ja aber wir werden
ja die entscheidung von damals heute
nicht revidieren denn hier ist ja
gefallen und wir sind mit dem angebot
was wir gemacht haben mit dem
zukunftsteam mit armin laschet und mit
markus söder mit unterstützung der
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel in diese
wahlen gegangen und die wahlen sind
nicht so ausgegangen wie wir uns alle
das aufhalten robin alexander hebt den
finger würden sie sagen robin alexander
am ende hat nicht wieso die cdu zerstört
sondern armin laschet ja ich glaube
keiner der beiden das ist auch
vielleicht ein bisschen große aufgabe
aber ich habe gerade den finger gehoben
weil die geschichte die peter altmaier
gesagt hat die stimmt aber da gibt es
noch eine weitere note nämlich wenn wir
uns erinnern hatte armin laschet ein
bündnis mit friedrich merz geschlossen
und hatte ihm versprochen dass er
wirtschaftsminister wird und der
wirtschaftsminister ist ja peter
altmaier also peter altmaier
überraschende parteinahme für markus
söder war vielleicht auch nicht nur
altruistisch motiviert ich glaube das
gehört zu der geschichte auch dazu
also lieber in alexander bei allem
respekt den ich für analytische
fähigkeiten habe ja ich will sagen ich
habe damals auch im bundesvorstand das
begründe die ich kenne markus söder seit
über zehn jahren weil ich damals
umweltminister in berlin war für
deutschland und er war das lange jahre
in bayern er war dann finanzminister
und ich habe in der korona pandemie mit
ihm sehr eng zusammenarbeiten dürfen mit
allen anderen mit armin laschet übrigens
auch wenn sie jetzt noch erzählen dass
sie auch in der flüchtlingspolitik eng
mit microsoft zusammengearbeitet haben
dann
habe ich auch mit ihnen auch nicht eng
zusammengearbeitet wenn ich mich recht
erinnere sie haben nichts zu denen
gehört die das lauthals immer gelobt und
gepriesen haben da hat sich an ihrer
unterstützung da hatten wir eher
unterstützung von unserem partner in der
großen koalition und auch die anderen
beiden die hier am tisch sitzen haben
damals diesen parteiübergreifenden
konsens mitgetragen und das hat uns
geholfen in alexander ausgerechnet
bacchus wieder friedrich merz verhindern
das ist sein wichtigstes interesse ja
markus söder hat ja nachdem er lange
gegen angela merkel gekämpft hat das war
auch die zeit an die peter altmaier
gerade erinnert hat hat markus söder ja
eine 180 grad wende gemacht er selber
sprach davon
hätte sich zum licht bekannt nachdem er
feuer auf der dunklen seite der macht
unterwegs war und in diesem bild ist
friedrich merz immer noch auf der
dunklen seite der macht ein friedrich
merz hält ja an seiner merkel kritik
fest und die idee die markus söder jetzt
von der zukunft der union hat ist das
gegenteil von der idee die er vor zwei
jahren von der zukunft der union hatte
und die sieht einen friedrich merz nicht
mehr vor also markus söder ist
vielleicht noch nicht ganz entschieden
wie er sich seine schwester partei
künftig wünscht aber es sich sicher
entschieden dass er sich nicht friedrich
merz und damit deren spiel zu daher die
frage ist doch schon auch ob markus
söder quasi die legitimation auch das
moralische recht hat über den künftigen
kurs der union zu bestimmen klar alle
lachen zurzeit über armin laschet aber
ich kann nur sagen die rolle von söder
an diesem desaster wird ja bisher
komplett unterschätzt ich meine man kann
im frühjahr einen machtkampf miteinander
austragen man kann ihn dann allerdings
so brutal machen dass derjenige der am
ende gewonnen hat schon so zerrupft und
zerzaust in diesen wahlkampf stolpert
nämlich durch die durch den scheinwerfer
den markus söder und seine freunde auf
sein schwächen gelegt hat also das ist
schon mal das ist schon mal ein ganz
besonderer vorgang gewesen und dann
dieses aggressive und unsolidarische
verhalten von markus söder den ganzen
wahlkampf über auch bis in diese tage
hinein da kann man nur sagen
herzlichen dank das ist schon selbst
verliebt und selbstzerstörerisch und
überhaupt macht sich die union in diesen
taten etwas leicht alles auf laschet und
sein wirklich sehr sehr unglücklichen
dabei kampf zu schieben ich meine wir
hatten die massen wäre meine nächste
frage gewesen macht man es sich macht es
sich die cdu csu oder
total ich meine wir können nur auf ein
paar personen schauen erinnern sich mal
an die kombination von
mode und andreas scheuer an wir hatten
es eben schon all das was in der
digitalisierung nicht geschehen ist da
kann man mal der bär oder peter altmaier
fragen dann hatten wir masken für faire
also abgeordnete die sich in der
schlimmsten krise der nachkriegszeit
auch noch persönlich selbst bereichern
man könnte die liste noch weiter
fortsetzen der abzug aus kabul
durch eine cdu verteidigungsministerin
mit zu verantworten ist auch nicht so
gut gelaufen also es gab schon genug
gute gründe mit
der performance der union in der
regierung nicht allzu zufrieden zu sein
und das hat sich jetzt nicht erst im
wahlkampf gezeigt und insofern war es
interessant an dieser stelle natürlich
auch die beiden journalistenkollegen
unbedingt zu diesem thema zu hören und
wir wandern jetzt mit ihrem
einverständnis natürlich zu dem was an
neuem vor uns liegt hubertus heil und
fragen uns wie muss man sich das
vorstellen jetzt treffen sich also gelb
und grün und werden brücken bauen und
dann kommt der olaf scholz und macht die
kaputt und sagt ich will meinen
mindestlohn von 12 auf
die positionen der drei parteien oder
aller parteien die wahlprogramme sind
bekannter unsere überzeugung aber sie
werden eines nicht erleben und ich
glaube das zeigt sich auch schon
zwischen fdp und bündnis 90 die grünen
die sich ja getroffen haben und
vertraulichkeit verhalten haben wir
werden nicht auch wenn sich das einige
wünschen koalitionsverhandlungen für das
ist auch eine frage des stils dass man
sich in die augen sieht ich will aber
ganz grundsätzlich sagen bei allen
unterschieden die es gibt die johannes
vogel auch beschrieben haben die katrin
göring eckardt beschrieben haben gibt es
auch eine grundhaltung und
ähnlichkeiten es gibt eine ähnlichkeit
aller demokratinnen demokraten das ist
die kontinuität in der außen-
sicherheits- politik bestimmte sachen
sind zur staatsraison unseres landes
gehören wie das existenzrecht israels
unsere verantwortung in der nato und
auch in der europäischen union und es
gibt eben politisch große aufgaben und
jetzt ist die frage wie man aus den
unterschiedlichen zugängen und auch
positionen fortschritt für deutschland
machen kann beim aufhalten des
menschengemachten klimawandels bei der
digitalisierung auch bei der demografie
die am arbeitsmarkt grosse rolle spielt
das sind die großen fragen dieser zeit
deshalb bin ich dabei wir müssen gucken
dass wir aus den unterschiedlichen
positionen gemeinsam neues machen okay
wenn jetzt christian gentner festhalten
parteivorsitzende der fdp am 27 09 also
am tag nach der wahl noch dieses sagt
dann heißt das was wenn man die
wahlprogramme von spd und grünen sieht
dann fehlt mir die vorstellungskraft
welches inhaltliche angebot herr scholz
und macht das auf begeisterung auch bei
herrn kühnert und bei fresken stößt wir
fragen auch gleich über das vogel aber
sie wollen und müssen natürlich auch
ihre wähler belohnte sie haben ja
versprechungen gemacht wesentlich mehr
als die union beispielsweise und klare
linien gezogen das heißt sie müssen auch
an ihre spd wähler denken und sie müssen
gegebenenfalls auch an eine völlig neu
zusammengesetzte spd-fraktion denken
sicherlich aber das gilt ja den grünen
und der fdp genauso wir müssen die
interessen auch der menschen die uns
vertrauen vertreten und wenn wir nicht
handeln ja das ist so das gehört zur
demokratie man tritt ja nicht für
positionen an und sagte hinterher er war
nichts aber wir müssen auch brücken über
themen bauen habe ich gehört das finde
ich eine gute idee und die frage ist ja
nicht nur fügt man jetzt puzzlesteine
zusammen sondern macht man neues bild
und jetzt glaube ich hab die fdp und die
spd ebenfalls eine gemeinsame erfahrung
wir haben koalitionen in den jan mit der
cdu/csu gehabt und die fdp hatte das
auch mal und wir haben erlebt dass das
koalition waren die in ihrer jeweiligen
zeit auch dinge gemacht haben aber es
wäre ja ich glaube auch das ist in der
krise nicht schlecht war dass wir auch
gemeinsames gemacht haben übrigens auch
parteiübergreifend ich kann mich an
einst erinnern ganz konkret als die
krise da war die korona krise und ist um
sozial schutzpaket ging um zum beispiel
meinem bereich die kurzarbeit heraus zu
holen haben fdp und grüne mit gestimmt
dass nämlich verantwortung und mit herrn
brinkhaus musste ich noch diskutieren
dagegen war sofern die schmutzige wäsche
mit der großen koalition gewaschen wir
wandern mal wenn sie einverstanden sind
kurz hier rüber herr vogel christian
lindner 27 09 große sorge wie kühnert
und esken überzeugt werden können und
ist ein gutes rot-grünes angebot gibt
warum sagt er dass sie es ging darum das
angebot von olaf scholz das kann ich
nicht beantworten welches angebot olaf
scholz uns macht wir haben den auftrag
von unseren wählerinnen und wählern ich
weiß jeder muss kompromisse machen ich
sehe ich das veränderte parteiensystem
das setzt alle unter verantwortung aber
ich bin schon der meinung es muss
natürlich grundsätzlich in die richtige
richtung gehen und ich glaube dass egal
in welcher konstellation man über das
warum wenn man damit anfängt wo wollen
wir denn hin wenn wir es vielleicht erst
mal schaffen was sie eben beschrieben
habe politik modus zu wechseln und
wieder langfristig zu denken das ist
eine chance bietet da haben wir trotzdem
immer noch große unterschiede
er weiß ich finde seine rentenpolitik in
den letzten jahren zukunftsvergessen mal
gucken wie wir wenn wir zusammensitzen
zusammenkommen bei der cdu stören mich
andere dinge in der gesellschaftspolitik
also wir alle haben unterschiede das
doch nichts neues
und jetzt versuchen wir unserer
verantwortung gerecht zu werden den wir
schauen wo gibt es den meisten wo gibt's
die meisten gemeinsamkeiten also ist die
meisten gemeistert übereinstimmung bei
einem weg in die zukunft das ist doch
unser job ich frage nochmal nach der spd
und auch der neuen zusammensetzung der
spd fraktion die spd ist sicherlich ein
bisschen mehr nach links gerutscht nicht
nur in ihrer wählerschaft sondern auch
in der fraktion was glauben sie
natürlich auch in der programmatik danke
herr altmaier
was brauchen sie
glauben sie kann man eben beispielsweise
in bezug auf den mindestlohn wo kann
dann kompromiss liegen würden sie sagen
die nächste erhöhung steht dann sowieso
an und dann verständigen wir uns das bis
zum soundsovielten diese zwölf euro
erreicht haben olaf scholz hat sie zehn
millionen arbeitnehmern versprochen also
jetzt reden ja erstmal wir und dann
loten wir mit beiden parteien union und
spd gemeinsamkeiten aus und das ist
jetzt der charmante versucht den gut
nachvollziehen kann dass wir doch dass
ich sage ich ganz ehrlich ich verstehe
dass sie als journalistin sagen das wäre
jetzt spannend als bürgerin finden sie
doch auch dass wir eine regierung
brauchen die langfristig trägt und das
und öffentliche streitereien über
unterschiede in den letzten jahren jetzt
nicht der stil waren der uns glaube ich
voran gebracht hat und erst gemeinsam zu
wollen dass er doch gut bis gestern war
die partei von frau göring-eckardt noch
die tabus partei ist sie das jetzt
plötzlich nicht mehr hervor ja ich habe
den eindruck dass wir zum beispiel beim
klimaschutz das ziel teilen der
unterschiede in den instrumenten und ob
wir da gemeinsamkeiten finden darüber
reden wir jetzt von göring eckardt dafür
sie noch beschimpfen als vertreterin der
verbots bata
ist viel zu schade
auch vorher nicht gemacht ich habe ein
wunderbares wort dafür gelesen
ermöglichung regeln und das ist
vielleicht besser entspricht das nicht
so schlecht
dann weiß man schon auch worum es
eigentlich geht aber ich glaube es gibt
wirklich nicht darum ob man sich jetzt
gegenseitig beschimpft oder nicht sonst
geht darum nach einem wahlkampf ja ich
meine sie haben christian lindner am
montag niveau man auch also ich glaube
immer noch ein bisschen in diesem modus
ist zu sagen jetzt haben wir die ganze
zeit jeweils um stimmen für unsere
eigene partei geworben und das haben wir
auch zugespitzt und mit härte und klar
und begeistert getan und am montag
danach muss man anfangen kompromisse zu
finden das ist ja auch nicht so ganz
einfach ist aber jetzt so ist auch gut
so dass dafür machen wir auch politik
dass das gelingt ich glaube nur dass das
diese vorstellung da putzen sich
irgendwas zusammen da bin ich ganz bei
hubertus heil das wird nicht
funktionieren sondern die frage ist ja
auch tieren wir uns erstmal an der
wirklichkeit die wirklichkeit ist
insbesondere was die klimakrise angeht
dramatisch da kam auch nicht mehr
darüber reden als erstes was kostet das
wen sollen wir müssen darüber reden wie
bewältigen wir das und da gibt es
verschiedene konzepte und ich weiß dass
es mit uns nicht einfach sein wird wir
haben mit ihm über den co2 preis
verhandelt und es war also der schwer
der härtesten krassesten verhandlungen
habe gesagt die spd ist gern der
problembär gewesen und das waren die
krassesten verhandlungen und wer am
meisten im weg stand dafür da
ambitioniert zu sein war urlaub deswegen
sollten jetzt nicht so tun als ob wir
uns schon wattebäuschen gegenseitig zu
werfen das werden harte verhandlungen
gegenseitig wahrscheinlich werden die
frage ob wir es hinbekommen 16 jahre
lang haben menschen immer wieder gesagt
wir fühlen uns im ländlichen raum
zurückgesetzt vergessen abend gehängt so
ob wir es hinbekommen eine politik zu
machen die stadt und land endlich
zusammen denkt und zusammenführt und
sagt hier wir sind hier ein gemeinsames
ganzes es mit den sogenannten
gleichwertigen lebensverhältnissen aus
der verfassung des meinen wir ernst wenn
das progressive parteien machen dann ist
es eine neue herausforderung dann geht
es nur darum was zu beklagen oder
irgendwie zu behaupten die einen denken
nur an die stadt und die anderen
vielleicht nur an seiten zusammen das
ist die frage vor der wir jetzt stehen
und das wird nicht einfach sein also ich
will jetzt nicht so tun als ob das schon
nicht geschätzt ist also wird mit der
spd nicht einfach sein bei der
klimakrise würde auch mit der fdp nicht
einfach sein die andere vorstellungen
von ordnungspolitik haben es würde mit
der union nicht einfach sein und
trotzdem sind die probleme riesig bei
ihnen herr heil es ist ja auch nicht
schwer zu sagen
als was alles christian lindner schon
klassifiziert wurde der hat dann wurde
ökonomie gemacht und ist ein luftikus
und kann nicht rechnen also auch da gibt
es auch nach der wahl bemerkenswert aber
auch da gibt es ja ein kaleidoskop
neben damit haben sie jetzt jede chance
dazu auch noch mal zu sagen was sie
eigentlich zu den wahlversprechen der
fdp denken war das wo du musst mal ich
glaube das wird uns tragen müssen von
den aufgaben her reden wenn wir
klimaschutz ernst meint und nicht nur
ziele in internationalen verträgen
eingehen wollen dann läuft deutschland
im tempo so weitermachen wie der
vergangenheit in einer riesen strom
liegt offensichtlich da andere nochmal
wir reden mit reden über die frage von
mindestens 100 terawattstunden jahre
2030 das heißt wir müssen um das zu
erreichen was die vermeidbare energien
ausbauen wir brauchen leitungen
infrastrukturen wasserstofftechnologie
und in der lounge ich kite kann dass
deutschland nicht weitermachen sonst
verlieren wir wirtschaftskraft und
verfehlen die klimaschutzziele
absolut wir brauchen nicht sechs jahre
damit eine windkraftanlage nämlich dass
wir brauchen mindestens eine zeit ich
sag mal verführt mir eher weniger als
sechs monate vor da muss tempo rein ich
will was zweites ansprechen und dass
meine praktischen beispiel zu machen ich
bin arbeitsminister ich weiß dass sich
die arbeitswelt rasant ändert durch
digitalisierung durch den umbau der
industriegesellschaft und die aufgabe
die wir haben das mitzuhelfen dass die
beschäftigten von heute auch die chance
haben die arbeit von morgen zu machen
dass der weg in eine weiterbildungs
republik oder sich konzepte bei der fdp
gar nicht so unähnlich sind denen der
grünen und bei uns wenn es zum beispiel
bei euch heißt das einen erwachsenen
bafög einzuführen also mitzuhelfen dass
menschen
mit love klingt so ein bisschen nach
krise aber der begriff finden wir schon
aber die idee einer präventiven
sozialpolitik sie mithilfe
arbeitslosigkeit zu verhindern bevor sie
entsteht ist glaube ich ein riesiges
projekt dass sicherheit und chancen im
wandel gibt und einen solchen projekten
würde ich gerne arbeiten und deshalb der
wahlkampf ist vorbei jetzt geht es darum
einen wählerinnen und wähler auftrag
umzusetzen es geht darum kompromisse zu
schmieden aber nicht auf dem kleinsten
gemeinsamen nenner sondern sie sind
großen aufreger werden mindestlohn name
genannt sie haben jetzt das mitleid
bafög noch mal erwähnt oder eben nicht
sondern das bafög für die menschen dann
gibt es natürlich auch noch eine
mitgliederbefragung
sie werden in partei zu organisieren
dass das was ausverhandelt wird von den
kollegen wird gefunden werden muss
rechnen sie damit ich glaube dass wir
jetzt mit einem die verhandlungen gehen
dass das in den parteien legitimiert
wird gilt für fdp bündnis 90/die grüne
spd im zweifelsfall sogar cdu ich weiß
nicht mehr einzeln leuten aber das ist
ein normaler vorgang aber ich will noch
einmal sagen eine frau illner weil ich
einmal eine lanze dafür brechen will
dass es gut ist das bündnis 90/die grüne
bei fdp bei uns auch nicht nur erfahrene
sitzen sondern viele jüngere die grünen
und die fdp haben sehr viel zuspruch von
jüngeren wählerinnen und wähler bekommen
respekt davor übrigens ich glaube liebe
fragen zeigt die jüngeren wählerinnen
und wähler wollen auch keine
konservative koalition und wir haben
eine fraktion in der auch jüngere sind
übrigens ganz spannende leute mit ganz
unterschiedlichen lebensgeschichten als
start-up-unternehmen und mit sehr vielen
menschen auch migration situation und
das tut der demokratie gut